I'd like to ask you Dr. Zakya if you
could explain what are the etiquets of
supplicating towards Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. The person should remember that
he should only ask from Allah and no one
else. Allah says in the Quran in surah
faty chapter number one verse number
five
there alone we worship there alone we
ask for help. You should ask only from
Allah subhanaa tala. Allah says in surah
chapter number 40 verse number 60 you
ask me and I will answer your prayer.
You can ask from Allah subhanana wa tala
anything even if it be a small thing or
a big thing no problem. We can ask Allah
subhanaa tala anything.
And furthermore,
we should ask Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
with humbleness and with humility.
That's point number three. Point number
four, when we ask Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala, we should ask with confirmed
hope that inshallah Allah is going to
answer our supplication. Number five, we
should ask Allah subhanana wa tala with
fear. We should ask with tawa fear of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. Number six,
we should ask Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
with extreme longingness that inshallah
we long this and he will answer our
prayer.
Besides these six points, there are some
additional things which are important
when a person supplicates. It's
preferable. For example,
a person should preferably be in voodoo
in ablution. It's not a fur. He can even
supplicate without being in woodoo. But
if he's like a person who's in prayer,
it's preferable that he's in voodoo.
Point number two, it's preferable that
he's facing the cabba while supplicating
though it's not a further. Point number
three, he should repeat his
supplication. It's preferable to repeat
as much as possible. And point number
four, he should ask Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala with single-mindedness and with
longingness. As our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said it's
mentioned in a say had ofdi had number
3479 that the beloved prophet wasallam
said that a person should ask Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala with
single-mindedness
and inshallah Allah will answer his
prayers and Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
does not like a person who asks with his
heart when it is toying with trifle
things. heart is not in one place. So
these are some of the tickets of a
person to Allah subhanaa tala.